[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
endgame class my name is Caleb Denby and
today I'm gonna be walking you through a
couple different end games one of which
was from my own game and one of which
was from the world champion so two
players with a lot alike I feel but
let's jump right into it if you caught
the road to 2000 I took you guys through
very much in depth a lot of the early
and middle game of my game against
Katarina and Emma Silva now I wanted to
take you in for a lot of a closer look
at the end game that was played there
because I think it was a really really
interesting end game with a lot to learn
from so let's look at the board we have
this Bishop on d6 and and in the game
rook takes d5 Bishop takes that fate
King takes f8 allows us to arrive at the
pure rook and pawn endgame so like I
said I want to walk you guys through
this one step by step so what do we have
going on here well of course we have
white with the extra pawn sitting there
on f2 and black is definitely going to
be on the back foot in this case now of
course if these two pawns were off the
board it would be a dead dead draw just
for example just to throw some nonsense
on the board if something like this
happened this game is always going to be
a draw three versus two is just well
known you know the the defending side is
is going to be able to draw but with the
be pawns on the board it's a very very
very different story
so I wanted to ask you guys how would
you go about trying to win this game if
you have the white pieces here let's
stop and think at the initial point in
this endgame this is always a point when
you want to stop and think right when
you enter the endgame and think about
you know some of the plants what you
want to be doing what your opponent is
probably gonna try to do to stop you so
already let's stop here and look for a
second
Cayla probably played Bishop takes f5
intentionally so get a material for this
lecture yes you guys are catching on
catching on rook b6 than rook d7 so yes
this was what was played in the game
chess King Rik b6 and bring the king
over cut off the white king or the black
king I think you mean and advance the
Kings side majority so yeah these are a
lot of great ideas and rook b6 rook d7
is a fantastic start to any kind of line
in in this case now there's actually an
alternate way of playing this position
obviously in any case goal number one is
keep this King out of the game goal
number two is get your King into the
game now some people were saying you
know while we're doing that let's
advance the Kings side majority and this
is actually not going to be the greatest
winning plan here these three pawns have
a difficult time making anything useful
happen against these two pawns that's
why usually the three versus two is just
a draw so my idea in the game was to
focus mainly on winning this be pawn and
more importantly preserving this B pawn
from white because if this B pun falls
off the board why it's gonna have a very
difficult time of winning this game so
priority number one is definitely make
sure that this b-pawn stays on the board
for white and try to get rid of this b4
pawn for black sort of at any cost and
the thing I went for in the game is
actually trying to get rid of these two
pawns so there are a couple ways to kind
of go about this one is to do what I did
in the game with rook b6 rook d4 and
rook d7 this is a great way of playing
it's the way that I played in game and I
definitely stand by this plan and the
point is this King gets locked on the
eighth-ranked and has a very very
difficult time of getting out now the
other way to play this is to actually go
the exact opposite approach rather than
and get behind this pawn the move rookie
4 is also very very much worth
considering and the point of this move
is that it focuses less on restricting
the black King
but we'll see later on in the game my
problem wasn't restricting the black
King my problem was getting the white
king into play so with the rook on e4
this now forces the black rook to b5 the
quote-unquote behind the pawn a good
idea but when this pawn isn't past being
behind it might actually be less useful
than being on the side for black and the
reason of course is that now my King has
great access to the entirety of the
board with my rook here to help guard it
along its journey so the move b3 would
make a lot of sense for white and then
from here you know we can kind of start
our march over to the Queen side of the
board and while the king is not cut off
from the seventh rank it is cut off from
the e-file and this is going to prove to
be a rather difficult endgame for black
as well but let's focus on what happened
in the game with rook b6 rook d4 and
rook b7
now the move age six was played and I
start with the move B 3 which is just
always I think going to be a very useful
move it takes away the c-4 square from
the rook and it gets this pawn off of
the Annoying second-ranked where if I
ever touch this F pawn I'm susceptible
to getting checked and being very very
upset about it and now the move Katarina
played in the game is actually a pretty
bad one it's the move g5 so why is g5 a
bad move what do you guys think at home
here
why is g5 a bad move
turns three V 2 into a 2v1 black wants
to trade pawns so mark actually turning
a 3 B 2 into 2 V 1 is I believe what
Katerina was hoping for in Katerina's
perfect world I believe what she wanted
to happen is this pawn lands on g4 and
now it's sort of restricting these two
pawns together but unfortunately this is
not necessarily what's going to happen
for Katarina here she was trying to just
trade down pawns to get closer to a draw
an endgame
so Great Wolf has the right idea and
Manny's idea is also very very relevant
as well taking is still losing for black
yeah and actually I think the move g4 is
is not ideal but this pawn on g5 would
do a good job of sort of restricting the
move f4 and it would make creating a
past upon a little bit more difficult
now that's not to say H takes g5 is like
a bad move by white I think it's
perfectly fine but I think the way that
I played is a little bit more principled
with the move h5 and now what's the
problem for a black with the move g5
well as Great Wolf said it weakens in
the seventh rank and now you know in a
far-off distant land you could kind of
imagine this king guarding in this Jeep
on threatening to come up to h7 and if
for example h5 ever gets played now if
this rook ever leaves the seventh rank
the move g6 is going to be playable for
black and the king can start kind of
maneuvering its way up the board now
this this might be a long way off
but the king would have a little bit of
shelter at the very least and would be
able to guard both of these Kings side
pawns very very well after sorry yeah
after b3 g5
now with the seventh rank totally
cutting the King off from the pawns the
problem is that these two pawns are
going to be very very huge weaknesses
that white can can very much attack in
many many cases so h5 by me was trying
to keep the most funds on the board as
possible which is generally a good thing
in rook end games in this case h6 g5
also very much winning but I do think
that this is the more principled
approach and now King g8 is already like
forced by black to have at least the
option to come to the seventh rank to
defend h6 if needed but yes very
seriously the problem for black now is
this h6 pawn is just another issue that
she is going to have to contend with now
it is time to come up with the winning
plan how do we make progress this is the
question
how do we make progress here still
getting paid in granola bars it's more
more packs of cheez-its these days more
packs of cheez-its someone discovered
that the granola bar tub expired a
little bit ago so not a lot of granola
bar fans these days
so you guys are stumbling upon the
problem here so we would love we would
love to put our King on e3 and then just
very easily win the game right I would
love to do that the issue is the second
you play King f3 Rick d3 is Chuck and
rook takes b3 and now you very much
have a game on your hands a game where
White is still probably better because
of these issues on the Kings side but a
game I would rather not be playing
compared to the endgame I just had where
I had a beep on on the board so King f3
not gonna cut it not gonna cut it
King f1 King you too well the issue
you're running into is that this rook is
going to land on e4 and then King e2 is
going to be highly illegal Black's next
move is rookie 4 unless you play King f3
King f1 rookie for f3 well now it's time
to calculate what is black in a play
after f3
what is black in a play after f3 line
doesn't end at f3 this is a great
calculation rule to follow whenever you
can sometimes you can't follow this rule
because it's just a little bit too
complicated but in general you can't
stop calculating until all the pieces
are safe and there's no very serious
direct forcing move left on the board so
obviously you can't stop calculating f3
because it's a very serious direct
threat of F take c4 so you know black is
gonna have to play something there you
have to come up with something for black
then if black makes the move that makes
a threat have to come up with something
for white and then if white makes the
move that makes a threat have to come up
with something for black have to keep
going for the calculation
kingi two attacks a black rook super
Kura can't stop there can't stop there
so here's the thing about end games when
you're playing an actual game with
plenty of time on the clock versus an
end game in a lecture right in the
perfect world you guys would get as far
as you just did which is we want to play
King f1 to King e2 rookie 4 is going to
stop us but now the move f3 is
challenging this rook
so rookie 3 is a natural move and now
rook takes before is the very sensible
idea rook takes f3 is check King g2 and
this rook moves away right you can get
this far on your own ignore those arrows
you can get this far on your own right
but then the question is you have to now
decide for yourself am i winning this
endgame so you have to evaluate from
that initial position if you're winning
here so what does that mean that means
you calculate the forcing line and then
you try to hold that position in your
head
and from here you start trying to think
about a winning plan so the question is
can you win this endgame so let's look
from this position here now
now in turn the game you would be doing
this in your head before you ever think
about playing the move f3 well actually
while you're thinking about playing the
move f3 but now are you winning this
game this is the question and how here
the king can march up the Kings side
wonder where the White King is going
well I said ignore those arrows I wasn't
joking because those arrows might not be
totally correct if you do just go for
this sort of business well you are
running the risk of leaving a g3 pawn
behind right if you play this move King
f5 leaving g3 behind and once again it's
going to be a bit of a game going to be
a bit of the game and you might be
thinking well aren't I just checkmating
black and you might be thinking that but
have you seen the mover Akef three
lately have you seen the movie f3 if
King takes pawn have you seen the movie
4 lately I've seen the move g4 lately
and it's it's a chess game believe me it
is a chess game
so are you winning this game
so yeah you guys are on the right track
here rook d7 is a great start but the
problem is g4 is going to be a very very
good move for black if you love black
play g4 well now all of a sudden your
king is going nowhere fast
and this pawn is going to be very very
weak and once again you are not going to
be satisfied with the oh well you might
be satisfied with that endgame you're
not going to be satisfied with this
endgame which is just going to be a draw
two versus one is even more cleanly a
draw than three versus two so you do
have to play the move king h3 first but
okay
King g7 by block and once again how do
you actually win this chess game if you
leave this g3 pawn behind you're sort of
asking for trouble right so how do you
win there's a very key maneuver that you
have to find rook b6 cut the King off
again okay you cut the King off and then
black starts passing like King aged
seven and then back and forth back and
forth all day long King g4 back and
forth back and forth
get the rook to g5 do you mean g6 g6
might make more sense
I mean King g4 is not a hard move to get
in right play King g4 whenever you want
the problem is playing King f5 is a lot
harder so my question is how do you make
tangible progress in this end game and
I'm not seeing anybody with with an idea
here
rook d7 or at age seven while you're not
getting to age seven right you're not
getting to age seven
back it on up here
the rook check and push the pun but I
mean okay okay
yeah you can only push the pawn so far
right like let's say you get this
position right okay so I should be I
should be putting this guy behind the
pawn let's say you get this position
right like you get you get here how do
you win you push the pawn
congratulations how do you win
bring the king over how you guys are
killing me
you guys are killing me
merge to c7
Marsh just he's easier said than done
I'll tell you something guys I think the
Sun game is drawn I don't know that it's
drawn but I think that it's drawn
started doing this I start doing this
start doing this I start doing this you
go over here I go up here it's not so
simple
so my question stands how do you win
this position
and like keep in mind all I did there oh
I did there was put this piece here put
this piece here and put this piece here
so it's very close to a draw for black
you have to be accurate
ah so pushing to be seven is a rather
classic mistake here so let's put that
on the board just briefly I'm sorry I
don't want spend too much time doing
this but let's put this on the board
right now this position is definitely
not winnable and let me explain why
black is going to pass like this forever
and ever and ever in a second you come
out over here you have no well sorry I
should put this guy back here first
obviously now you have absolutely
nowhere to go with your king I will
check you forever and ever and ever and
then the second this pawn touches b7
this King cannot really invade so this
one most definitely a draw
alright I'm seeing some reasonably
reasonably good ideas reasonably good
ideas
rook b4 and g4 bring king to the a file
and guide the pawn to the Queen side
okay so it looks like their idea is to
do this and just start running I think
the issue there is that blacks King is
going to get a little bit too active in
this case you start running I go over
here all of a sudden this pawns attacks
you start running some more I give you
some checks and it's not so easy to
touch any of these guys right like rook
c4 maybe but I don't know this is this
is also looking tough you're giving
black a little bit too much freedom here
I think what else we got what else we
got
push the pawn check on g6 then b6 so
this is actually sort of the best that
white can hope for if we can achieve
this position then we have a lot to be
thankful for and so what's the
difference here compared to what we just
looked at well now for one the black
King is very much shut out of the game
and two our King is definitely still
going to have shelter once we get to the
seventh rank our rook can always block
any checks from behind so this is sort
of the ideal to aim for with white now
of course black doesn't have to let you
get here for example what if in in this
position black plays the move king h7
what happens then
maybe then king g4 and bring out the
Kings so that's actually still totally
accurate we don't have to necessarily be
going to the Queen side in this case
because now if King age 7 if King f5
Rick f1 check is going to be enough for
some repetition by black but
unfortunately I don't think it's gonna
be enough from more than that actually
maybe this is also winning at this point
the point is we need this King on g7 so
that after I move like King g4 we can
kind of battle this king with our own
King with something like king f7 for
example now if King f5 these types of
moves do start to have a little bit more
validity I think for example rook f3 and
okay maybe this one is actually also
winning the more I look at it but the
point is we do need to get the King out
from behind this pawn so in the game I
will finally reveal what was played I
played the move King g4 and it turns out
this is actually a little bit of an
inaccuracy I think the position is still
winning but the wind gets a lot harder
after the move
King g4 now what's the reason for that
well the reason for that is that all of
our winning positions come with our rook
on b6 this was sort of the key to the
endgame and that that you guys
eventually did land on here we don't
need to play rook b8 and bring this pawn
up
we need the rook up so we have threats
of coming to here we also have the
option to give our Kings shelter with
the rook in front of the king so rook b6
is the key to it all this is the
absolute killer winning move no chance
for black after rook b6 pretty much
every line is winning I was trying to
find some tricky way to make it a draw
but of course I could not because route
b6 is just too strong rook b6 you almost
always win this game now but in the game
I played King g4 and of course this
allows black the opportunity to prevent
rook b6 by playing these slightly
weird-looking rook c6 taking control of
this rink for himself now after work c6
the
I do believe is still winning after some
analysis I did but we'll take a look at
that in just a moment in the game rook
d3 was played now I give this check and
this check landing on b6 finally King g7
and now I push the pawn forward I get
rich e6 check and b6 and now this game
was very very easily won she did play
this move g4 in an effort to win my age
5 pawn but it did not really matter just
bring the King over and at the end of
the day one rook is better than no rooks
and she resigned in this position as I
quickly showed in the road mm lecture so
what was the key the key was putting
this rook on b6 this is the key to all
of the winning variations if you don't
put this work on b6 you have a very very
difficult time of actually winning this
game but just for argument's sake let's
say you didn't get the rook to be 6
because in the game my opponent had this
opportunity for a single turn to play
rook c6 and make my life a little bit
harder how do you win this position well
you win this position because your King
still gets into the game unfortunately
the upside now for white is that well we
do not control the 6th rank we are able
to support sort of all of our weak pawns
with the rook from behind so how do we
do that well we do that with the move
rook c4 rook could be 6 or pawn to b4
and we do still get this rook to defend
our pawn from the side which is actually
kind of what we want here with pawns on
the other side of the board as well and
now for example after King f6 rookie 4
cuts the King off b5 King f3 King of 7
g4 and now we have actually constructed
a pretty substantial wall that keeps the
black King out of the game and from here
it is very very smooth sailing to put
this King on the Queen side and push
these pawns forward this kind of nice
setup by white here to create this wall
around the black King allows you to go
ahead and win this position is this my
best win I think maybe she was the
highest rated person that have beaten I
think maybe Aaron Reuben ski was a few
points higher than
her when I defeated him I was going to
show my game against Aaron Berger Pinsky
cuz I love showing that game but we
didn't have time in the road 2000
lecture so this is the furthest we got
Rick could be 5 Rick g5 I don't know
what you mean by that rookie or turkey
what Catarina resigned on the spot had I
played rugby six nine I doubt it she
didn't resign until I was up a full rook
in King versus rook so you know
understandably okay let's move along
then to the next endgame if there are no
questions here the last thing I was
gonna point out is what the endgame
could have looked like if this pawn
didn't move to g5 but honestly it's a
lot of the same with this rook to
staying on the seventh rank rather than
the sixth rank to keep this King out of
play and to keep an eye on this this
week pawn and yeah I don't even want to
get in to all of that nonsense yet let's
just move along to the next game I want
to look at which is a game between
Magnus Carlsen and Anish Deary from the
chest wrapped up days ago with Magnus
defeating a niche in the finals so I
wanted to look at this end game because
it on the surface looks like a
reasonably simple position right you
have five versus five on the Queen side
of the board
maybe you slightly prefer the white
pieces due to the fact that his
structure is better of course
this structure looking slightly
fractured compared to whites nice clean
pawns single pawn Island but I feel like
many people myself included would
struggle to make anything out of this
position anything substantial and so I
wanted to look at how Magnus Carlsen
actually poses some very very serious
problems to a nice giri here
do we have a stream schedule we do have
a schedule which you can check on our
website see it was just called org me
personally I actually appear on the
channel pretty regularly for these
classes Monday and Wednesday nights but
other than that I kind of come and go
from week to week okay
Great Wolf has seen this game before but
can't remember what happened
thank goodness otherwise this lecture
would be less useful but let's talk
about right so there are a few things
going on here that you can try to do
with white number one is obviously you
want to find some way to target the e5
pawn that's priority number one
and that's why Magnus immediately
launched into one into a maneuver
designed at targeting the e5 pawn number
two is as always you want to find some
activity for this rook and this work on
h1 is already reasonably active Magnus
didn't really commit it to any of these
squares on the H file for a little bit
but it's still always threatening to
jump into one of these squares at a
moment's notice
so immediately in the game nye p1 is the
choice by Magnus Carlsen probably not
the first move
that would occur to you guys or I mean
anybody Nyepi one I don't think is
anybody's first move that they consider
but the point of course is that it's
heading for the f3 square it's heading
for the best square to target the e5
pawn and use this weakness for as much
as worth so nigh b1 first move now b5
comes on the board by a nice giri as
always we've seen this idea before we've
mentioned it before the weaker side
generally tries to trade pawns when they
are trying to hold a position
well the stronger side wants to keep as
many pawns on the board as possible so
b5 even though it looks a little bit
ugly
Anish is just trading pawns and getting
down to a slightly more comfortable
endgame
now 92 was played by magnus carlsen of
course now if b takes a for winning a
pawn happens Knight f3 is winning the e5
pawn in exchange with district having no
squares to keep the pond safe so giri
plays the move rook g3 instead guarding
the f3 square trying to prevent the
knight from actually getting there and
magnus takes the time out of his busy
schedule to defend his a4 pawn now and
Anish as we said wants to trade pawns so
he does just that with BA for BA for
immediately now unleashes next move is
actually pretty important he immediately
plays the move c5 and this is the kind
of defense that you would expect to see
from a nice giri he's trying to get as
many pawns off the board as possible and
he's wasting absolutely no time to do it
this is one of those positions where you
don't necessarily want to just sit
around forever and give your opponent
you know sort of infinite time to figure
out any way to kind of crack through
your defenses and break whatever
fortress you're trying to set up you
want to immediately simplify you want to
get out of this game before this game
you know sucks the life out of you
so c5 aiming for c4 immediately is great
by Anish now Magnus doesn't panic and
just plays the move Knight f1 some more
funny maneuvers with this night hitting
this rook the rook comes to f3 now and
now the move King d1 Magnus once again
playing very very calm and very
collected gets his King into the attack
sort of indirectly by bringing this King
to e2 it's tough to see how that's
influencing the e5 pawn but the King on
e2 makes the circle move away which
gives this knight freedom to come back
to f3 it's all coming back to attacking
that e5 pawn see for now by Anish was
the plan and so he follows through on it
King two attacks this rook the rook
moves back to f7 guarding some of these
squares on the seventh rank I will
mention that f7 actually was not my
favorite square
that giri chose here I think actually f6
or f8 would make a little bit more sense
he likely didn't want to go to f6
because it's sort of asking for a fork
but I don't like f7 because I think in
general we would love to play Knight f7
in response to this rook trying to
invade when we are guarding sort of all
of the squares on the H file of course
we're not guarding h7 but we're
neutralizing h7 by cutting this rook off
here so Rick f7 I don't think it's a bad
move but it does prevent the knight from
using this square in any case now we do
see the move Knight back to d2 by Magnus
of course with this King booting this
rook out of the way Magnus once again
it's all about the e5 pawn heading back
for the f3 square we see the move rook
over to g7 and now of course this is
once again preventing Knight f3 this one
would be good enough for Gary to take
off enough pawns to draw the game so
Magnus not wanting to allow rook g2 now
plays the move King f3 and suddenly the
King which was sitting on c1 has now
come to f3 and given a little bit of
more time you can imagine this king is
actually going to be the attacker
Magnussen's looking for to get at e5
King d7 was played and now rook age 5 is
very very natural this piece was always
going to be able to attack the e punt
and it does so immediately and now
rather than play a move like King e6 and
sort of waits for Magnus to figure it
out Geary once again goes down a very
very forcing line that he had calculated
out to be a drawn endgame and that is a
great way to play the defensive side of
these positions you always want to be
looking for that escape hatch where you
you know find the back door and say I'm
out of this position while the move King
e6
is I think perfectly fine still for
black it's definitely the type of move
where it's like alright I'm willing to
be here for a while I am definitely
willing to sit here and play this
position until the end of
for example a move like King F 2 is
already eyeing some ideas here for
example c5 Knight f3
now Knight of 7 is forced the Stewart
can come into f5 the sunette can come
back to d2 for example at some point and
it's it's not gonna be the easiest
position in the world by any stretch of
the imagination for black so rook g1
instead was a nice Gary's choice like I
said going for the forcing lines to get
as much stuff off the board as possible
and get into an endgame Geary knows he
should be able to draw so rook g1 great
move by Geary now Eric takes e5 is sort
of the only only attempt for Magnus and
now the idea of course by Gary is to go
after the C pawn from behind with Roxy 1
why is black not capturing on d3 well
because black wants to win the c2 pawn
and C takes D 3 would make winning the C
to pawn very very difficult now
nothing better for white to do then take
on c4 he tries something weird like d4
rook takes C 2 is going to be good
enough when this Knight has no good
squares and this C pawn is going to be
just as relevant as these two pawns with
the C pawn already with some threats of
promotion so instead we see the move and
it takes d4 Knight takes e4 do you take
c4 rook takes c2 and now after okay five
rook takes c4 we have this pure rook
endgame
this is what Anish saw from afar and
this is what he chose to go for in game
and now this is actually an incredibly
difficult position I know it doesn't
look that difficult it looks like well
either why it's winning worries not how
complicated can it be there's only three
pawns on the board but oh my god I have
spent so much time looking at this
position I think the move rook a8 is the
absolute most testing variation here by
Magnus and this is not what was actually
played in the game
believe it or not there is exactly one
move for Giri that draws this position
so I challenge you guys at home to find
it see if you can figure it out here
black to move and draw only one way to
do it
every Rickon game is a draw well in this
case every rook endgame is lost
besides for exactly one and that's the
rook end game after black's next move
all right nobody's willing to venture a
guess yet this one this one is tough
this one is pretty deep
pretty pretty deep
I keep says c5 mecir says King c6
mahmoud says king c6 beltran says rook
c1 c4 c5 s'more king c sixes and yes of
course the only move to draw is not c5
not King c6 not rook c3 check I would
have thought at least oh yeah one person
has suggested it now on command
it is the move rook c1 and this is kind
of a kind of crazy that this is the only
move that draws so why is Rick c1 the
only move that draws well because it is
in this case the most flexible move and
you'll see this a lot in these type of
end games if you guys are familiar with
Reddy's you know famous endgame study
with a king the secret to drawing that
endgame study is to sort of ride the
line with your king
come diagonally down the board and
always be able to venture off in either
direction depending on what your
opponent place and that's the same idea
here with rook c1 you take these simple
ideas from you know in the most famous
studies of all time and they seem to
kind of pop up and have implications in
these very real game positions so why is
rick c1 the only move that draws why am
i saying it's the most flexible move
well because it's not revealing blacks
intentions king c6 is revealing blacks
intentions it's saying i will stop the a
pawn but by removing this king from the
e pawn by a step it allows the move e5
to actually win the game you can compare
this with the move rook c1 rook c1 is
always going to be a useful move because
the rook is going to have to get behind
I either passed pawn but it's not
revealing which direction the rook is
going so now if you play the move a5 we
can play the move king of c6 it's fine
to reveal our intentions now because
you've spent a move on a5 already rather
than a 5 now if you play e5 King b7 is
stopping the a pawn rook the eights and
now our rook can finally corral this
pawn just in time
now compare this to king c6 first when
of course II five rook c1 and now rook
d8 is actually the only winning move if
rook over to a one King e4 and this pawn
is in fact going to promote now there is
one crazy crazy line that's a I seemed
to have lost somewhere along the way
yeah so a five king c6 e 5 no not this
one a 6 rather king b6 e 5 yeah this one
is is is rather crazy here so if white
goes ahead and plays this way with a5 a6
and then e 5 once again believe it or
not there is only one way to draw this
position and there are just so many of
these only moves dispersed throughout
this endgame that it's it's honestly
obscene and you could talk about it for
hours and analyze it for hours I am just
gonna reveal this one to you
here you absolutely must play the move
c5 and the reason why is because if you
get behind the a pawn now King e4 if you
play c5 here you're just a little bit
too slow and this pawn is promoting
after a six and if you play the move
work II won now the move King f4 comes
on the board and if you play c5 here now
a7 now see for now rook c8 gets behind
the pawn and if king a7 or XE for king
b6 and rookie for I do believe is
winning this game now compare that with
c5 immediately when after this move king
a4 we have c4 e6 c3 e 7 means your key 1
check or even see - just to be showy
and this pawn is is arriving just in
time for counter play so fun stuff now
why doesn't Rick see three Chuck win
that's an excellent question
well the point is you're forcing the
king up the board and you don't even
have the flexibility of coming to e1 if
you need it so once again in Kingston
six losses to e5 only move and after
Rick's e1 look D eight is the the crazy
way to win the game cutting off the king
from the e pawn so rook a a would have
been fun to see instead we saw the move
rook d5 check and in now King e6 and now
after a five it is a much more trivial
draw here for a nice giri so black to
move and draw there are actually a few
ways to do it but a niche managed to
find a way that lost
a couple people saying rook a four
everybody wants to play you're okay for
and you are correct okay for is great to
stop this a pawn in its tracks and the
point is you play you're okay for before
White has time to get the rook out from
the side of the pond while we
desperately wanted the rook on the side
of the pond and the first endgame we
looked at here the rook is actually
better served in front of the pawn
rather than from the side so Rock a fort
would draw or exceed three trek followed
by work a3 would draw even the move
kingi seven would draw c6 however that
would lose the game due to rook d8 when
this rook gets in front of the pond and
Anish made a similar mistake here and
while in the previous positions rook c1
was the only move in this case it is the
losing move the difference here of
course being that he gave this rook too
much freedom and this trick is going to
get to a eight and you can't really stop
it in the game and continue to wreak f1
check can you to work a 100k eights and
now after king d6 a6 is locking the king
over to the Kings side king c6 King III
and here unfortunately every move is
losing king b6 might have put up the
best effort but you can just simply push
this pawn all the way up the board
no capturing here and your c5 ideas are
a little bit too late
in this case King f2 is actually a
killer move to stop the rook from
getting behind the pawn c4 for example e
six and there's just nothing to be done
just a tempo to slow and making a night
instead of a queen for some reason but
it doesn't matter
although sorry no we we definitely
should not allow should not allow this
sorry excuse me
Black has rook f1 check here with with a
crazy draw but white does have the move
rook c8 instead and then this one is
going to be a win but Queens and rook f1
check would be probably the funniest
draw I've seen in a long time
and the point being you just cannot
escape perpetual check after see one
Queen this would be absolutely insane
but none of that even came close to
happening instead in the game we saw the
mover key one checking at four and now
black is just far too slow far far far
too slow
kingi four and black resigned Magnus was
just going to crawl his way up the board
and make a queen
you're welcome miles thanks for coming
around and watching the show well I
think that is just about going to do it
for us here on the end game class it is
now just about 8:00 p.m. so as a quick
review of this last end game here I
loved a nice Gary's defensive play
while the Knights are still on the board
he played very very concretely and very
quickly and that's very very important
because it's the type of position where
if you sit around for too long you're
bound to slip up somewhere and then your
opponent's gonna snatch your a5 pawn and
once the e5 pawn dies you'll lose the
game so he played very quickly trading
off pawns as quickly as he could and he
went for a forcing line that it
calculated to what should be a draw but
then unfortunately he kind of relaxed a
bit too much and allowed Magnus to get
that winning position once again and the
key point to take away from that period
endgame is flexibility look for the
flexible moves the moves that give
yourself the most options in any given
line that your opponent can choose and
those moves are often correct lessons
from Reddy's famous end game study if
you're familiar with it as I said that
does it for us here on the YouTube
channel tonight thank you guys so much
for joining me we will be continuing
with another class on the twitch channel
directly after this from 8:00 to 9:00
p.m. so be sure to head over there check
it out if you want more of me talking at
you tonight's if nots thank you so much
for joining me my name is Caleb Denby
and I will see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]